Credit Union
[Music]
hey right now we're just trying to
baskets I don't like it we gotta dig
deep on that end if you want to rest
rest down here okay find the corner and
take a break but down there we don't
rush it's 12 to 24 in the pay and that
makes me so happy
that is so awesome boy it doesn't get
any better than that who doesn't want to
play for Becky Hammond you can just see
the Joy on her face pretty cool stuff
right there and the aces are just one
went away from delivering this city
another professional Championship Aces
only need to win one game of the next
three to Capture the Crown or one of the
next two in Connecticut then it's done
it's just that simple one win from
history one of the reasons why this team
is a win away from the title is the play
of Kelsey plug she got back on track
thanks to some kind words from MVP Asia
Wilson
I told her she needed to get her
together okay at the end of the day
that's what she needs to do we drafted
her to do that everything so I made her
make sure that we make sure she
understood that we we need her to make
shots and I know it sounds harsh but KP
is a pro and she went out there and took
care of business yes she did the Aces
and Son now tip off tomorrow six o'clock
on ESPN we have a correspondent in
Connecticut we'll have more coverage
tomorrow prior to kickoff